well yes uh maros tanchos and joanna
gamolska have been jailed for a total of
25 years between them following a
lengthy three-month trial here at
bristol crown court it relates uh to
human trafficking which they carried out
for at least seven years here in the
city
tanchos and gamolska would travel to
orphanages
and
slum camps in slovakia to recruit
vulnerable mainly men on the promise of
a better life of work here in the uk
they would be brought over and promised
that they would be given accommodation
and half of their wages it was a very
different story when these victims
arrived in the city they were kept
inside a house in bristol uh made to
sleep on filthy mattresses uh to ten of
them uh in a room sharing uh one
bathroom they were locked inside uh the
house and none of the money of course
never went to them uh tanchos and
gomolska uh made them work day and night
in the days at a hand car wash on the
outskirts of the center of bristol and
various other jobs uh at night they were
always on the promise that they would um
get money eventually and they had come
in good faith to send money back to
their families but they were kept as
slaves and today at the judge told them
both in the dock that they preyed on
desperate and damaged people as they
were sentenced to 16 years tantros nine
years gamolska for trafficking
exploitation and forced labor offences
now this is an investigation which was
led by the national crime agency as well
as their counterparts in slovakia it
took a number of years
to
get those victims many of whom had
returned to slovakia to give evidence um
we have heard from one of the victims
who has given an interview anonymously
and this is what they had to say i was
living in an unknown country
i didn't know what to do
we had no life
for example if we wanted to go to the
shop we had to let him know
i knew i could not leave
there was nothing i could do i had to
stay we had no money we had no id
we had to stay
when i came back to slovakia i reported
him to the slovak police force
but they didn't believe me
also there wasn't enough evidence
against him and i want to make sure that
the same thing won't happen again to
other people
well uh tanchos and gamoska were
arrested in 2017
and that is when the investigation then
began in earliest and it emerged that
over the seven years or so that they
were running this human trafficking ring
the pair had netted nearly 300 000
pounds from the wages of course that
weren't passed on they took out credit
cards loans in the names of these
vulnerable people they would take them
to the banks
and set up bank accounts
but of course they kept control of all
of that money
throughout this operation uh mark
morrison from the national crime agency
has given that the organization's
reaction
we've got the whole range we've got
multiple victims 29 people prepared to
say that they were victims is a huge
number
we've got all the aggravating factors of
having their id cards withheld the
beatings the excessive hours um the
injuries one will say about his broken
arm where he had to go and get it fixed
and then he had him back working the
next day car washing with his unbroken
arm um
the
the mental anguish that these men and
women have gone through is absolutely
abhorrent
this was a couple who essentially saw
their victims as commodities in order to
make money for themselves they lived a
lavish lifestyle cars casinos uh online
gambling and that is what they spent
their money on the living conditions
that these
victims were made to live in uh were
absolutely squalid as i say filthy
mattresses on the floor the ncaa
interviewed more than 40 victims but
they believe there were many more
involved
in this exploitation ring which ran
between 2010 and
2017 and they are now starting prison
sentences totaling 25 years